former FBI director Andrew McCabe comes
out and says that the 25th amendment was
considered against President Trump the
media struggled to exonerate Ilhan Omar
of anti-semitism and we talked about the
one-year anniversary of parkland I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
all righty so we're gonna get to all the
news in it is a big news day today first
we need to talk about the u.s. national
debt remember 2008 where there's this
guy named Obama he was elected and the
US national debt at the time was 10
trillion dollars today the debt is
nearly 22 trillion dollars it is rising
at like a hockey stick if you don't
think that we're sitting on a house of
cards you're living with your head in
the sand but since you're listening to
the podcast you're already smarter than
the average American so what exactly is
your plan can you afford another hit to
your retirement like the last downturn
when the S&P dropped 50% well this is
why you should have put at least some of
your money in a hedge against inflation
and uncertainty with some precious
metals gold as a safe haven against
uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
the company I trust with precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group and right
now thanks to a little-known IRS tax law
you can even move your IRA or eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver it's perfect for people who
want to protect their hard-earned
retirement savings from any future
geopolitical uncertainty look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else Gold tends to
safeguard savings Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews and an A+
rating with the Better Business Bureau
contact Birch gold group get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals see if diversifying into gold and
silver makes some sense for you that
comprehensive 16-page kit reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
to get that no-cost no-obligation kit
text been - for seven four seven four
seven again
text been my name - 47 47 47 - get that
no cost at no obligation kit alrighty so
the big news today is that former acting
FBI director Andrew McCabe now has I
believe a new book coming out he has an
interview with Scott Pelley of 60
minutes and in this interview in this
interview he tells Scott Pelley that he
and a bunch of other people at the FBI
and inside the DOJ considered recruiting
cabinet members to invoke the 25th
amendment here's Scott Pelley reporting
that from CBS this morning the most
illuminating and surprising thing in the
interview to me were these eight days in
May when all of these things were
happening behind the scenes that the
American people really didn't know about
there were meetings at the Justice
Department in which it was discussed
whether the vice president and a
majority of the cabinet could
brought together to remove the president
of the United States under the 25th
amendment these were the eight days from
commis firing to the point that robert
muller
was appointed special counsel and the
highest levels of American law
enforcement were trying to figure out
what to do with the president okay and
this is fully insane right if you recall
this was first reported by the New York
Times they reported the Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein who's always been
seen by President Trump as sort of anti
Trump as the guy who is allowing robert
muller to run wild in the mall or
investigation the New York Times
reported last year that rod Rosenstein
had basically convened meetings about
whether the 25th amendment could be used
to declare president Trump mentally
unfit that's not his job that was not
his job that was the Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein not his job right
the the decision as to whether the 25th
amendment could be invoked or should be
invoked would have to be initiated by at
least a sitting cabinet member you would
imagine it can't just be some low-level
staffer over at the attorney general's
office who decides you know let's have
some internal discussions about removing
the President of the United States
specifically in the aftermath of the
president firing the FBI director which
by the way he has every right to do
Trump has responded in a pair of tweets
on Thursday morning after Rosenstein
said the McCabe's accounts of the
discussion was inaccurate and factually
incorrect Trump responded in Twitter
forum he said disgraced FBI acting
director Andrew McCain pretends to be a
poor little angel when in fact he was a
big part of the crooked Hillary scandal
and the Russia hoax a puppet for leak
and James Comey IG report on mccabe was
devastating part of insurance policy in
case i won many of the FBI top brass
were fired forced to leave her left
mchavez wife received big dollars from
clinton people for her campaign he gave
Hillary a pass mccabe is a disgrace to
the FBI and a disgrace to our country
all capitals make America great again
now Trump is not wrong to rip into
Andrew McCabe you'll recall that Andrew
McCabe was originally fired for lack of
candor he was fired last year he had
denied any wrongdoing and he claimed
after he was fired that he was innocent
and he justified his leak by claiming
that Jim's coming knew about it he had
leaked to the media that there were
developments in the Hillary Clinton case
he had leaked that to The Wall Street
Journal and then he had lied about it
internally Katie Pavlich has a piece
over at the hill about this a few
back she says that McCabe hired a K
Street lobbying firm to set up a legal
fund where he raised $500,000 from
sympathetic leftists who viewed his
firing is unjust even cruel since it
happened just two days before his
retirement you remember he was stripped
of his retirement because of the firing
the truth is McCabe's lime was worse
than previously imagined and cited for
his firing speculation about his lack of
candor was overwhelmingly confirmed by a
long-awaited Office of the Inspector
General report late last week which
showed the McCabe's behavior was not
only dishonest but that he lied multiple
times under oath to OIG investigators
and FBI agents Oh IG investigators
concluded his repeated lying was
calculated and beneficial to him not the
Bureau or the agents who work inside of
it according to the report as detailed
in this report the OIG found that then
Deputy Director Andrew McCabe lacked
candor including under oath on multiple
occasions in connection with describing
his role in connection with a disclosure
to the Wall Street Journal and that
conduct violated FBI code the OIG also
concluded that McCabe's disclosure of
the existence of an ongoing
investigation in the manner described in
this report violated the FBI's and
department's media policy and
constituted misconduct now does that
mean that mccabe was part of the
quote-unquote russia hoax does that mean
that mccabe was actively undermining the
president in 2016 it doesn't mean that
because if you recall the reason that he
was fired was because he leaked
information about hillary clinton to the
wall street journal' nonetheless mccabe
has some honesty problems obviously and
him suggesting that inside the DOJ there
were actual meetings about getting rid
of President Trump is pretty insane
stuff according to the New York Times
they reported last year that rod
Rosenstein who is currently the acting
Attorney General had suggested or he's
the Deputy Attorney General he suggested
that he secretly record President Trump
in the White House which is pretty
insane Rosenstein disputed the account a
Justice Department official said he made
the remark sarcastically the accounts
tended to back up Rosen's teens account
but McCabe told Pelley that Rosen's
scenes offer to wear a wire was made
more than once and that he ultimately
took it to the lawyers at the FBI to
discuss McCabe who is named acting
director of the bureau after commis
Fyren launched obstruction of justice
and counterintelligence investigations
into whether trump obstructed justice by
firing Comey now that's the part where
mckay becomes part of the quote unquote
deep state launching investigations that
are entirely baseless or based on
speculation just because you don't like
the air boss
fired that is not justifiable there was
no evidence at the time that obstruction
of justice was what had caused president
Trump to fire two fire
James Comey President Trump said pretty
openly the reason that he fired James
Comey is because Comey wouldn't just say
that he wasn't under investigation at
the time and yet McCabe launched these
obstruction of justice and
counterintelligence investigations into
Trump that looks pretty damning it looks
pretty damning mccabe says I was very
concerned that I was able to put the
Russia case on absolutely solid grounds
in indelible fashion that were where I
removed too quickly or reassigned were
fired that the case could not be closed
or vanished in the night without a trace
now again that is not his job the FBI is
still a part of the executive branch the
President of the United States still has
unitary power over that executive branch
if the president were to step in and
actively stop an investigation then
presumably that would be obstruction of
justice you'd have whistleblowers and
the president would be in danger of
impeachment but that is not what
happened here
and McCabe's saying that he was setting
in process a bunch of Investigations
specifically with an eye toward the
possibility that Trump was some sort of
foreign agent is pretty crazy stuff in
an excerpt of the book published
Thursday in the Atlantic is he has a new
book coming out which is why he's doing
all of this mccabe describes a phone
call he received from trump on his first
full day on the job as Acting Director
of the FBI
according to McCabe Trump told him he
had hundreds of messages from FBI people
saying how happy they are that I fired
Comey you know boy it's incredible it's
such a great thing people are really
happy about the fact that directors gone
it's just remarkable what people are
saying Trump said according to McCabe
have you seen that are you seeing that
too mckay but was eventually fired in
March 2018 so McCabe coming forward with
this bombshell once again is gonna raise
the specter that President Trump is not
in the wrong when he says that there
were motivated people inside the DOJ and
the FBI who are attempting to oust him
from office without proper evidence if
that is true if inside the DOJ there
were actual meetings about invoking the
25th amendment without a single member
of trumps cabinet asking for it or
asking for that investigation that's
pretty insane stuff again that is not
their job that is not their job and
Trump has every right to be
extraordinarily upset about all of that
it meanwhile President Trump is deciding
whether or not
to sign this border wall deal it appears
pretty obvious that today President
Trump is going to sign the border wall
deal it doesn't actually provide tons of
money for the border wall it provides
about one point three seven five billion
dollars for additional border fencing
according to the New York Times Congress
will move quickly on Thursday to pass a
border security deal that deprives
President Trump of what might be his
last chance to build his wall
it doesn't really deprive him of the
chance I mean President Trump may be
reelected maybe he uses his executive
powers in order to build more fencing
along the drug corridors
the New York Times though is hopeful
that Trump signs this into law the
Senate will vote first on the
legislation which includes the seven
remaining bills to keep the final
quarter of the government open through
the end of September House and Senate
negotiators unveiled than 1159 page bill
just before midnight on Thursday leaving
little time for lawmakers to actually
digest its contents first of all this
kind of stuff has to stop this this is
just not the way government was ever
supposed to work that negotiators were
supposed to jump 1200 page bills in
front of the people voting on it the
night before
number one no bill should be this long
every bill should be about three pages
long in English that people can
understand with a legislative synopsis
and should be posted 24 hours at least
before voting and we should have a
chance and an opportunity to peruse the
actual bill dropping 1200 page omnibus
packages is just a way for legislators
to escape responsibility for their
culpability in writing garbage bills
that are just crap sandwiches passage is
expected tonight when the house takes it
up Senator Charles Grassley Republican
of Iowa and the President Pro Tem of the
Senate began Thursday's session by
praying that President Trump will sign
the bill senator Mitch McConnell of
Kentucky the majority leader said the
agreement is something both sides should
view as an important step passing the
bill McConnell said in remarks on the
Senate floor will provide the certainty
of a fully functioning federal
government bottom line is that nobody
has the taste for another government
shutdown at this point which is why
President Trump is likely to sign this
into law the final result not a lot of
wall gets built and Coulter hardest-hit
and President Trump
I guess gets the political victory of
being able to point to the Democrats and
say these folks don't care about border
security going into 2020 the border
security compromise which is tucked into
the forty nine billion dollar portion of
the bill that funds the Department of
Homeland Security represents the most
stinging legislative defeat of mr.
Trump's presidency according to the New
York Times it provides one point three
seven five billion
dollars for 55 miles of Steel folks two
pence steel post fencing a pail
comparisons the 5.7 billion dollar
request for more than 200 miles of steel
or concrete wall the president wanted is
actually less in mileage and money than
what was included in the deal the
president rejected in December but the
money allocated for fencing and
immigration detention was more than what
the left flank of the Democratic Party
had wanted because they wanted to
actually abolish immigration and customs
enforcement so is it a good deal no it's
a garbage deal is Trump gonna sign it
probably will he tried to find another
way to build some of this border fencing
I'm sure that he will it is a sign of
bad negotiation by the president at the
very least it's a sign of bad
negotiation so there are two takeaways
the president is not the great
negotiator who claims to me when it
comes to negotiating with Democrats this
is the second time he escapes of
Democrats you'll recall a couple of
years ago he went around Paul Ryan and
Mitch McConnell and just signed a deal
straight with the Democrats giving them
everything they wanted on the budget
he's not a great negotiator okay just
end of story
the president is not number two it
demonstrates once again Democrats do not
care very much about border security and
they are willing to allow the board to
remain a thoroughfare for drugs and
gangs and illegal immigration if it
means dealing President Trump a
political blow okay in just a second I
want to get to the anti-semitism
controversy that continues on the
Democratic side of the aisle first let's
talk about you getting a suit that fits
you better I know you think you can go
down and pick up a suit at a department
store from the rack and it looks good
doesn't it looks like you're wearing a
tarp instead you should go over to endo
Chino endo Chino is the world's most
exciting made-to-measure menswear
company they make suits and shirts to
your exact measurements for an
unparalleled fit and comfort you don't
feel like James Bond go to an endo
chinos store they let you pick all of
your customizations they measure you out
for a suit that is custom tailored to
you if you're getting married they have
tons of options for people looking to
outfit their wedding party guys love the
wide selection of high quality fabrics
and colors to choose from not to mention
you can personalize the details
including lapel lining pockets buttons
you can write your own monogram here's
how it works you visit a stylist at
their showroom they will take your
measurements personally or you can
measure yourself at home and shop online
at endo chinos con get all of those
personalizations and then you just wait
and the suit arrives and it is ready to
wear it fits you great this week my
listeners can be at any premium Indo
Chino suit for just 359 bucks at Indo
chinos calm when you enter promo code
Shapiro's at checkout that is 50%
off the regular price from
made-to-measure premium suit plus
shipping is free Indo Chino comm promo
code Shapiro for any premium suit for
just 359 bucks and free shipping
it's an incredible deal for a premium
made-to-measure suit once you go custom
you're not gonna want to go back check
out enzo Chino comm use that promo code
Shapiro's to let them know that we sent
you an to get that special deal three
hundred fifty nine bucks for a suit
alright so the president if he signs
this will be dealing a blow to his own
border agenda there's just no way around
that however going into 2020 does that
have any actual impact the answer is
actually no over the last month the
president has gained substantially in
his average approval ratings in the
gallup tracking poll the president is up
something like seven percent over the
last month and a half
despite the government shutdown despite
all of this why because the more that
the president can show the democrats in
the proper light the more he can show
how radical they are the better it will
be for him we live in a binary system
president trumps approval ratings are
not completely dependent on president
trump much of his approval rating is
dependent on how terrible the democrats
are and fortunately for president trump
the democrats are pretty damn terrible
speaking of which in just a second i
wanna get to the latest in the Ilhan
omar controversy so Ilhan omar continues
to be a horrible congress person just an
awful awful congress person yesterday
she made a fool of herself when she was
interviewing Elliott Abrams Elliott
Abrams is the special envoy to Venezuela
Elliott Abrams has been a lifelong envoy
to South America during the 1980s he
worked with a bunch of governments in
South America now you'll have to recall
that in 1980s there were serious
conflicts in South America in which the
Soviet Union was specifically attempting
to overthrow certain governments in
South America and Latin and Central
America attempting to overthrow those
governments and put in place communist
dictatorships and the United States was
deeply involved in funding a lot of
regimes that were bad but the question
is were those regimes actually worse
than communist dictatorships the answer
was no nonetheless is it true that the
United States has unclean hands in South
America of course that's true
Elliott Abrams was working for the
Reagan administration he was not in
favor of human rights violations he was
in the middle of a cold war and he was
attempting to make changes in South
America and work with governments making
changes in South America they would
eventually lead to democracy so
he worked for example in El Salvador in
El Salvador there was a civil war
between a communist uprising a communist
front group that was run basically by
the Soviet Union and funded by the
Soviet Union the United States backed
these el salvadorian government which
was a dictatorship in 1984 there was an
election in El Salvador and that became
that began the process of transition
away from military military dictatorship
and toward a democracy that did not
violate human rights in the same way
during the same period the United States
took in hundreds of thousands of
Salvadorian refugees so it is simply not
true that the Reagan administration the
Clinton administration they turned a
blind eye to all of the human rights
violations in El Salvador Omar was Ilhan
Omar was was asking Elliott Abrams
questions and you have to understand the
reason that she was going hard after
Elliott Abrams was not really because of
things she suspected that he did back in
the 1980s that is not the real reason
she's going hard after him
the real reason Ilhan Omar is going hard
after him is because she is a defender
of the Maduro regime so for a lady who
is complaining about human rights
violations in the 1980s she's sure doing
an amazing job of defending one of the
worst human rights violators on planet
earth Nicolas Maduro and the socialist
evil regime that exists in Venezuela say
Oh Hannah Maher went after Elliott
Abrams in the most vicious possible way
wouldn't even allow him to answer
questions the u.s. policy in El Salvador
was a fabulous achievement yes or no do
you still think so from the day that
president Duarte was elected in a free
election to this day El Salvador has
been a democracy that's a fabulous
achievement yes sir no do you think that
massacre was a fabulous achievement that
happened under our watch that is a
ridiculous question yes or no no I I am
NOT going to respond to that kind of
personal attack which is not a question
okay and of course he is exactly right
also Democrats should know by now no
means no no does not mean yes Hey the
idea that she can say do you believe in
human rights violations and he says no
is
I'll take that as yes well then take a
hike
take a hike lady I mean what what vile
nastiness by the way she doesn't even
know she's talking about I mean she was
issues questioning him about iran-contra
and she was mispronouncing half of her
words she legitimately doesn't know
anything about the topic she's
questioning about her staff preps her
and then she goes out and ask questions
by mispronouncing the actual words that
she's supposed to be saying in 1991 you
pleaded guilty to two counts of
withholding information from Congress
regarding your involvement in the
iran-contra affair for which you were
later burned by President George HW Bush
on February 8th 1982 you testified
before the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee about US policy in El Salvador
in that hearing you dismissed as
communist propaganda report about the
massacre of el mozote a okay so she
doesn't know she's talking about and
she's a nasty human being to not even
allow Abrams to answer the questions I
don't what the purpose of these hearings
is other than to provide these sort of
moments for the fresh faces of the
Democratic Party so fresh so face to
demonstrate how they can destroy
Republicans and then we just clip out
the part where he answers and then we
pretend that she did an amazing job of
tearing him down but that is not the the
extent of the defense of Ilhan Omar so
one omar did that yesterday if a
republican congress person did that to
any democratic nominee everybody would
be up in arms in the media instead she
was cheered as a real truth teller by
members of the media but it's not just
that
Ilhan omar is a lifelong anti-semite or
at least a career-long anti-semite her
record of anti-semitism is clear and
convincing it was not just that she
tweeted something out that was
anti-semitic last weekend as I said with
regard to Ralph Northam you have to
judge people by their body of work when
that photo came out of Ralph Northam
from 1985 I asked the question do you
actually think that Ralph Northam is
racist that was a racist thing to do do
you think that Ralph Northam is actually
a racist based on his 59 years on this
planet do you think that overall he is a
human being today is a racist and the
answer by way of his record is probably
no it's probably known the same thing is
true of Attorney General Mark herring
in the same state who dressed up as a
rapper in 1980 the point that I'm making
is that people say dumb ignorant stuff
sometimes they do dumb ignorant stuff
sometimes and when people do dumb and
ignorant stuff and we can a judge that
it has been dumb and ignorant then
forgiveness is in the cards forgiveness
is not in the cards when you have a long
record of doing bad stuff and then you
say a thing when you have a long record
of saying things and then you say
another thing right at that point
forgiveness is not in the cards nor
should we adjudicate your statement in
the same way we would as if it was the
first time that somebody else had said
it Hey Ilhan Omar has a long record of
this sort of garbage we will go through
that record briefly Hey Ilhan Omar you
know she tweeted out let's start with
her her Israel has hypnotized the world
tweet as she started out in 2012 and she
tweeted quote Israel has hypnotized the
world may Allah awaken the people and
help them to see the evil doings of
Israel hashtag Gaza hashtag Palestine
hashtag Israel and then she still says
like today that Israel does not have a
right to exist right that's a thing that
she still says like today okay so that
was 2012
nothing has changed nothing has changed
in the last month she said Israel has no
right to exist as a Jewish state I'll
show you that clip in just a second so
nothing has change there's a long record
here and I'll explain why this matters
in just a second first let's talk about
the safety and security of your home
rings mission is to make neighborhood
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you will get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone that is thanks to HD video and
two-way audio features on ring devices
my family has a ring device on our outer
fence it is spectacular ly useful we can
tell who is showing up if I'm away from
home I can answer the doorbell so people
don't know whether I'm home or not as a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with a ring video doorbell and a
motion-activated floodlight cam the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home this stuff is really necessary
a lot of break-ins occurring in in major
cities around the country and a lot of
those break-ins happen when somebody
rings the doorbell to determine if your
home and then they break into your house
ring prevents that because you can pick
up your phone anywhere they don't know
if you're home or not and you can call
the cops just go to ring comm slash Ben
and
ring.com / ben ring.com / ben and that
helps you get that special offer on a
ring starterkit' available right now
ring calm / man make your home and your
neighborhood safer by extension okay
before I get to the rest of Ilhan Omar
and her long record of anti-semitism
I've been getting emails from people
asking me to define anti-semitism it's
because people are doing this routine on
the left where they say being
anti-israel doesn't mean the are
anti-semitic opposing certain actions
that Israel takes does not mean that
you're anti-semitic obviously opposing
actions taken by the Israeli government
or perspectives of the Israeli
government on particular issues does not
mean that you are anti-semitic
I'm not anti-american and I oppose some
of the policies of every administration
I'm not anti-israel obviously and I
oppose many policies of the Israeli
government most obviously this 2005 pull
out from the Gaza Strip that turned over
the entire place to the to the terrorist
group Hamas if that's not anti-semitic
what is anti-semitic is believing one
that Israel does not have a right to
exist to treating Israel in a way that
you would never treat any other state so
holding them to a standard you would
hold no other state and three suggesting
that Jewish that Jews everywhere are
responsible for these specific actions
of Israel and punishing Jews as a
collective for the actions of the
Israeli government so you see this in
Europe a lot every time Israel's in a
war people try to burn down synagogues
that's obviously anti-semitism
it is also anti-semitic to buy into
giant anti-jewish conspiracy theories
the idea that the Jews are manipulating
world events as a collective we get
together at our synagogues and we
control the weather or in the financial
system in the media that's anti-semitic
conspiracy theory nonsense the problem
for Alejandro Maher is that she believes
a lot of these things and it is obvious
from her statements and her activities
that she does believe a lot of these
things by the way my suggestion that
this is what anti-semitism is is not
unique to me it is the State Department
definition of anti-semitism here are
some of the examples of anti-semitism
that the plenary and Bucharest decided
to declare in the Stockholm declaration
are anti-semitic a calling for aiding or
justifying the killing or harming of
Jews in the name of radical ideology or
an extremist view of religion making
mendacious dehumanizing demonizing or
stereotypical allegations about Jews as
such or the power of Jews as collective
such as especially but not exclusively
the myth about a world Jewish conspiracy
or of Jews controlling the media economy
government or other societal in
stitute accusing Jews as a people of
being responsible for real or imagined
wrongdoing committed by a single Jewish
person or group or even for acts
committed by non-jews accusing the
juices of people or Israel of a state as
a state of inventing or exaggerating the
holocaust accusing Jewish citizens of
being more loyal to Israel is the dual
loyalty canard that is engaged in openly
by Rashid its Labe or the alleged
priorities of Jews worldwide than to the
interests of their own Nations denying
the Jewish people their right to
self-determination for example by
claiming that the existence of the State
of Israel is a racist endeavor okay that
is definitional anti-semitism according
to the State Department here's a lehand
Omar doing exactly that in the last
month and I see is what you'll Institute
law that recognizes that as a Jewish
state and does not recognize the other
religions that are that are living in it
and we still uphold it as a democracy in
the Middle East
I almost chuckle because I know that if
you know we we say we see that in in any
other society we would criticize that we
would call it out we do that to Iran we
do that to any other place that sort of
upholds its religion okay she's just
lying now she's lying openly Muslims
have more rights in his robe than they
do in any Muslim state anywhere in the
Middle East
Islam is is a religion that is protected
by Israeli law mosques are protected by
Israeli law the Islamic walk controls
the holiest site in Judaism the Temple
Mount itself she's just full of it right
and in her suggestion that Israel cannot
exist as a Jewish state isn't
anti-semitic canard and fully
incontinent in keeping with everything
that she has said in the past drawing
comparisons of contemporary Israeli
policy to that of the Nazis another
State Department recognized version of
anti-semitism using symbols and images
associated with classical anti-semitism
claims of Jews killing Jesus of the
blood libel to characterize Israel or
Israelis my bottom line is this if we
were going to analyze anti-semitism and
I've done this before on the program it
seems to me that in the modern world
there are three types of anti-semitism
one is old school old school religious
anti-semitism the belief that Judaism is
a gutter religion in the view of Louis
Farrakhan that is sort of classical
anti-semitism that Judaism is inherently
evil and terrible and wrong and there
or it must be wiped out right that is
classical anti-semitism you can say
religious anti-semitism then there is
racial anti-semitism the idea that the
Jews as a race are nefarious evil
attempting to undermine society right
that is that is the second type of
anti-semitism you see that mostly
associated with sort of alt-right Nazi s
groups the idea that the Jews are a
separate group of people genetically and
and therefore they have an agenda all
their own and then there's the left-wing
version of anti-semitism and that is
that there that the world is made up of
people who are more privileged and less
privileged Jews are more privileged
therefore the Jews are engaging in
activity to keep their privilege to
themselves and that crosses over a lot
with intersectional theory
so people wonder how it is that the far
left which doesn't share a lot of
priorities with radical Islam seems to
share priorities when it comes to Israel
and anti-semitism and the answer is
because there's a lot of crossover
radical Islam says religiously Jews are
evil and also they cross over into Nazi
s territory with the Jews are the sons
of pigs and monkeys Israel is a gutter
state Israel shouldn't exist and then
you have the far left which says that
Israel obviously is a victimising
exploiting States and uses its world
power in order to in order to hypnotize
the world there's a lot of crossover
between these two things so though
Hunnam are anti-semitic yes she's an
things medic she's been antes medic for
years there's nothing new here there
were those of us were calling it out for
legitimately months before she was
elected as soon as she started making
the national stage I mean this is a
woman who appeared on a show with a guy
who suggested that Israel was the Jewish
Isis and she joked on that show about
people in the United States you know
taking too seriously and being too
afraid of al-qaeda and Hezbollah is back
from 2013 I remember when I was in
college I took a terrorism class and
yeah there was see you go there is a lab
for luck there was there was a class
ideology you do this and so it was it
was the the thing that was interesting
in the class was every time the the
professor said okay that he sort of like
his shoulders went up and you know okay
okay so yeah we can laugh about al Qaeda
we can laugh about Hezbollah she
suggested at the time by the way that
it's American action in the Middle East
that causes terrorism in the Middle East
which is of course a trope that is used
by radical Islamists all over the world
so there's nothing new Under the Sun
there's a reason el-hammam are
celebrated with Linda Sarsour during the
women's March there's a reason that she
interviewed with that same guy that same
anti-semite that she was talking to
right there she interviewed with that
guy again in January 2017 there's a
reason that in less than two weeks she's
supposed to speak at an event next to an
open anti-semitic Pro terror leader but
we're supposed to pretend that she's not
an anti-semite the reason that this is
relevant I will explain in just one
second the reason I'm laying all of this
out I'll explain first let's talk about
how you protect yourself when the
founders crafted the Constitution the
first thing they did was to make sacred
the rights of the individual to share
their ideas without limitation by their
government the second right they
numerated was the right of the
population to protect that speech and
their own persons with force you know
how strongly I believed in those
principles I'm a gun owner and owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different this is
why Bravo Company manufacturing was
started it was started in a garage by a
Marine veteran more than two decades ago
to build a professional-grade product
that meets combat standards BCM believes
the same level of protection should be
provided to every American regardless of
whether they are a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment and
they assume that each rifle leaving
their shop will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or a
soldier overseas each components of a
BCM rifle is hand assembled and tested
by Americans to a life-saving standard
BCM feels a moral responsibility as
Americans to provide tools that will not
fail the user when it's not just a paper
target but someone coming to do them
harm to learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG comm where you can discover
more about their product special offers
and upcoming news that is Bravo Company
MFG comm if you need more convincing
check them out at youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA great company
wonderful people and their product is
Bravo Company MFG calm go check it out
right now all right in a second I'm
gonna get to why it is important to lay
out Ilhan Omar's entire history because
doing so completely deflates the media's
attempts to defend her and the Democrats
attempts to defend her I'll explain it
in just one second but first we're gonna
have to go and subscribe over at sailor
comm for $9.99 a month you can get a
subscription the daily wire when you do
you get the rest of this show live you
get two additional hours every day of
this show every afternoon and you can
ask me questions during our radio breaks
so as you know those last two hours are
part of a three-hour package a
syndicated show that goes out to
hundreds of stations all around the
country but you can only listen to old
episodes if you're a subscriber at daily
wire you missed the show well now you
can listen to it commercial free by the
way you go over a daily wire and check
that out for 99 dollars a year you get
all that stuff you get to be part of the
day to our backstage ask me questions
when I do the radio show during the
breaks I answer questions sometimes you
get to do all those things and get this
the very greatest in beverage vessels
leftist years hot or cold tumblr for 99
bucks a years that's a solid deal go
check it out right now subscribe over at
YouTube and iTunes as well make sure
that you do so so that you get our
Sunday special when you subscribe to the
daily where you I should get the Sunday
special on Saturday so you can actually
watch stuff early which is pretty
awesome so you won't have to even spend
one day without me I know I know
what would a dream what a dream you get
all those things when you subscribe go
check it out right now we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so the reason to lay out Ilhan Omar's
entire record here is to suggest that
when she makes an anti-semitic comment
in 2019 that is consistent with
anti-semitic commentaries she's been
issuing for legitimately ten years for
every moment she's been in the public
eye that this is not in fact a break
from her perspective it is an integral
part to her perspective and we should be
treating her the same way publicly that
the Republicans treated Steve King and
the reason that Steve King went under
the bus is because Steve King for years
had been saying stuff that was really
really on the line and there was a way
to interpret some of those things as not
nefarious and then all of that exploded
when he made these comments about white
nationalism and why should we treat
white nationalism as a term of no value
and once he did that it was like okay
well now we have to go back and look at
his whole record in that light with illa
Han Omar you didn't even need this
comment to do it she's apologized for
anti-semitism two times in the last
month
that's Houlihan Omar is now the reason I
also bring this up is because the media
have attempted to suggest that President
Trump in Ohio and Omar are somehow alike
when it comes to the issue of
anti-semitism this is plainly absurd it
is plainly absurd and frankly it's
insulting
so it's insulting to the intelligence
and now listen President Trump has said
stuff that can be perceived as
anti-semitic he has done stuff that can
be perceived as engaging in anti-semitic
tropes the reason this came up is
because yesterday we'll start at the
beginning
President Trump suggested Ilhan Omar
should resign say here was president
Trump yesterday saying that ohan Omar
should resign now she should resign but
she shouldn't resign because she tweeted
out Nancy's met a thing over the weekend
she should resign because she's an
anti-semite she should be kicked off her
committees certainly not be on the House
Foreign Affairs Committee for God's sake
because she is a she's an anti-semite
for as long as she has been in public
life and she has never once wavered from
that sentiment ever she may have you may
been cudgelled into saying that you made
a mild booboo but she's as anti-semitic
as she ever was we laid out her record
here was President Trump though focusing
in this mistake he focuses in on the
anti-semitic trope that she used over
the weekend as though that's the real
problem not the long record of
anti-semitism that preceded it and
engaged with with this particular
comment
anti-semitism has no place in the United
States Congress
Omar is terrible what she said and I
think she should either resign from
Congress or she should certainly
resigned from the House Foreign Affairs
Committee what she said is so
deep-seated in her heart that her lame
apology and that's what it was it was
lame and she didn't mean a word of it
was just not appropriate I think she
should resign from Congress okay Trump
is exactly right when he says this is
deep-seated in her heart that is obvious
from every action all of them are
consistent there has never been a point
a point where you can say that this is a
philo sematic person or even a neutral
sematic person like there's no way to do
that none so Ilhan Omar naturally went
back at Trump by suggesting that he's a
racist and a bigot and all this stuff
says hi Donald Trump you've trafficked
in hate your whole life against Jews
Muslims indigenous immigrants black
people and more I learned from people
impacted by my words when will you okay
that is a lie she has not learned from
people impacted by her words it's a
bunch of nonsense yesterday on the
program I read you a piece from the Twin
Cities Tribune from from Minnie in
Minneapolis star-tribune in which Jewish
leaders went to OHANA Omar years ago and
tried to have a sit-down with her an
anti-semitic intervention and came away
completely disturbed
by everything that they had heard so
she's just lying about that the
misdirection by the media from Omar to
Trump is a very convenient ploy but it
is not realistic for a few reasons
number one Ilhan Omar's apology was
complete bunk the reason it was bunk is
because she went right back to engaging
in the same stereotypical tropes that
she used a minute before she just got
rid of a little bit of the conspiracy
theory so what she did is she says
Jewish money is responsible for American
Israel support AIPAC and then she
apologized she said oh I guess that was
offensive but it's a PAC money that's
responsible for Jewish American support
I mean for for America's support of
Israel and that is that is carving it
back just enough so that we can pretend
it's not anti-semitic but again every
comment that she's made for ten years
has been basically anti-semitic when it
comes to Israel and Jews so I'm not sure
what we're supposed to take away from
that also does this seem like a person
who is deeply deeply regretful of her
activity yesterday she sent out an email
that was raising money off the entire
issue
hey Adam Rubenstein tweeted this out if
you go to Ilhan Omar dot-com if you go
to then she actually is raising money
off of this
saying we will not be silent stand with
Ilhan we will not be silenced we will
not be silenced
notice rank of silence you were trying
to say that you say terrible terrible
things and that you've taken terrible
positions and associated with terrible
people all of which is true does this
seem like the the activity of a person
who is deeply regretful of her actions
here was Ilhan Omar being asked about
this by a CNN reporter did she stop and
say listen I am I've already said I'm
deeply sorry about this it was a mistake
it came out of ignorance and I've
learned from it no here's how she acts
went out when asked about it what a
nasty human being she turns to Manu Raju
who's a reporter for CNN by the way and
she says what's wrong with you what's
wrong for even asking the question yes
obviously this is a person who is
completely completely apology ridden I
mean this is a person who feels complete
penance in her heart clearly now the
media rushed to her defense
naturally the media rushed her defense
they suggest that the reason that she's
being attacked is not because she has a
long history of anti-semitism the reason
that she is the reason she has attacked
is because she's a Muslim so here's
Chris Cuomo doing that idiotic routine
this moronic block of wood on CNN
suggesting that the reason people are
angry Doha Omar is not because she has a
long record of anti-semitism but because
she's a Muslim woman and we just can't
stand a Muslim woman in Congress right
sure I mean by the way worth noting I've
stated on the show I've stated on the
show that I was happy that Congress
changed its rules so that Muslim women
could wear hijab on the floor I think
it's a good thing I was against Trump's
Muslim ban when he first proposed it
back in 2015 but apparently the reason
that I'm anti ohon Omar has nothing to
do with a radical anti-semitism it's
just that she is a Somali woman who
happens to be Muslim now to the
president he's calling for Omar to get
out and that is interesting because he
seemed to say something very similar to
what Omar said when addressing the
Republican Jewish coalition in 2015
you're not going to support
because I don't want your money you want
to control your own politician that's
fine now why is it different it's
because Omar's Muslim and wears a hijab
I hear a lot of that and it's not right
especially when you remember that this
president has been down the road of
intolerance more than most
okay so there's Chris Cuomo as we met
routine Jake Tapper did this routine as
well he turned it into kind of a stick
on his show which you know I like Jake
his reporter but I thought that this was
really ham-fisted and and not fair I'll
explain in just second so Jake Tapper on
CNN yesterday turned the Ilhan Omar
scandal against President Trump by
playing old clips of President Trump say
engaging in anti-semitic tropes here was
Tapper doing this with the help of his
producers noting that this White House
finds more offensive than a politician
feeding into stereotypes about Jews and
Jewish money and controlling politicians
which is what congresswoman Omar is
accused of having done you know you're
not gonna support me because I don't
like your money you don't want to give
me money okay but that's okay you want
to control your own politician that's
fine I'm sorry that was the wrong clip
control room I want the the Omar clip
give us the omar clip there it wait no
that's not it either that's a deleted
Donald Trump retweet from 2016 please
the Omar tweet can you show it please
that's not this isn't it either it is
unbelievable okay so a couple of things
that are worth noting about the various
clips that Jake Tapper shows right that
first of all the clip of Trump speaking
is at the Republican Jewish coalition so
he's speaking at the Republican Jewish
coalition and he followed that statement
up by saying I too have engaged in
trying to buy politicians okay so a
little context there is necessary it
doesn't mean that he wasn't engaging in
an awkward and ignorant anti-semitic
trope he was and it doesn't mean that
when he retweeted something from
alt-right accounts what she was doing
consistently in 2016 that that was not
forwarding the aspirations of the
alt-right I was the number one
recipients of anti-semitism online in
2016 from the all right so I know this
better than anyone
however if you're going to suggest that
the real proud this is why the media
have been trying to boil down Ilhan
omars in to this particular statement
they don't want to talk about her entire
record because if they talk about her
entire record then the question becomes
why was she elected as an open
anti-semite in the first place why are
Democrats tolerating her continue to
open anti-semitism if they can boil
- oh she said a bad thing well Trump has
said bad things in the past - then it
makes it easy to ignore the fact that
Trump is also the most pro-israel
president in American history that he
has Jewish grandchildren that his
daughter is a convert to Judaism his
son-in-law who is probably his top
staffer is also a Jew it makes it very
easy to ignore all of those things when
you focus in on the individual
statements now as I said as I said you
have to analyze bi said this at the very
outset of this monologue you have to
analyze people by the bulk of their work
so if Trump says an ignorance stereotype
about Jews in front of the RJC well
simultaneously being incredibly proud
you across his business life across his
administration in his family life then
you say okay probably this comes from
ignorance
if however in an open anti-semite four
years says the same thing then maybe we
not maybe we shouldn't take it exactly
the same way if Ralph Northam dressed in
blackface in 1985 then spent the next 30
years caring for poor black children in
the inner city in his doctor's office I
think maybe we should take that as him
as a as a notion of ignorance as opposed
to an actual KKK member who spent 30
years terrorizing black people and
burning crosses on their lawn dressing
up in blackface in other words the
activity itself can be bad in both
contexts but how we adjudicate the
person based on the activity changes
based on the lifetime of experience so
by just saying but the real problem is
Ilhan Omar's comment not Ilhan Omar's
viewpoint what the left is doing is
escaping culpability for their own
complicity and anti-semitism that's
what's happening here
they are pushing against Trump in order
to avoid the fact that the left has
become very very comfortable with
anti-semitism in their own ranks and
look at the media tried to defend ohon
Omar here's Brooke Baldwin on CNN saying
well you know what
you know Ilhan Omar apologize so we
should let it go at this point she's
apologized twice in the last month hey
and she has a long history of
anti-semitic viewpoints and yet CNN is
the ugh she apologized we're done here
really so if Steve King had apologized
we do think CNN would have said you know
we're done here nothing more to see of
course not of course not but here was
Brooke Baldwin doing that routine
yesterday everyone is offended by
something today
Emmit ISM okay anti-semitic a but if we
are we are going
hang on hang on I think that I have
everyone resigned hang on for stupid
saying sir she apologized a little while
and said yeah maybe that's an apology or
not well your role she apologized okay
we just played three clips from the
candidate and then the man the President
himself correct tell me how many times
he's apologized for those comments
oh well slow your roll she apologized
her apology meant nothing when her
entire viewpoint is laced with
anti-semitism I say that we should
accept apologies when the apologies are
credible and when it looks like somebody
made a mistake not when they said
something completely in keeping with her
view this wasn't a gaffe by ill hen Omar
this was in keeping with her viewpoint
and that's what CNN wishes you to ignore
a Nancy Pelosi I thought had the most
telling take on all of this a Nancy
Pelosi was asked about whether Ilhan
Omar would lose her committee
assignments the same way Steve King did
and she said she said no she said a
newcomer member of Congress has
apologised for her remarks it took them
what 13 years to notice Steve King he so
first of all she's already comparing
Ilhan Omar to Steve King so she knows
exactly what Ilhan Omar is because Nancy
Pelosi believes that Steve King is a
deep-seated racist so she knows what it
what's what's the lesson here you get 12
years of free anti-semitism before
anybody gets to do anything that because
the right was too slow to awaken to
Steve King that therefore Ilhan Omar who
is perfectly obvious significantly more
obvious in her anti-semitism then Steve
King was in his racism until the last
few months that now we are that then
that she's got I guess a dozen year
reign of anti-semitism before her before
Nancy Pelosi decides to pay attention to
it the reality is Democrats know exactly
what L hen Omar is and they're keeping
her on these committees because she is a
fresh face that's all they care about
all they care about is pretending that
they are part of this intersectional
pyramid that trumps all else it's really
disgusting and Nancy Pelosi admits as
much that that that's that's an awful
justification right imagine a
justification where somebody does
something wrong and you say well you've
done something wrong for 12 years and
then you finally acknowledge it so I
guess I get to do something wrong for 12
years that is not a justification that
is Nancy Pelosi admitting that in her
view Ilhan Omar is Steve King but she's
not going to do anything about it
because Republicans were too slow on
Steve King way to take the moral high
ground there Nancy the reality is that
no henro Maher will remain
so long as she wishes to remain because
the Democrats are fine fine with
anti-semitism in their ranks they have
been for years they've been hosting
dozens of Congress people who routinely
meet with Louis Farrakhan in their
caucus for years and we're all supposed
to overlook that because President Trump
said some stuff that we engaged in two
anti-semitic tropes that was bad stuff
but that did not mesh with his career
record again a difference between that
and statements that completely mesh with
your career record which is the state of
the case where a sheet it's alive it's
the state of the case for Maxine Waters
it's the state of the case for Ilhan
Omar all righty let's get to let's get
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like today
so yesterday since I played the Soviet
national anthem in honor of Bernie
Sanders and AOC
I that got me thinking about great
national anthems and of course perhaps
the greatest national anthem is the
French national anthem the lemon La
Marseillaise and the best use of La
Marseillaise comes in the greatest movie
of all time Casablanca this is the best
scene from the best movie of all time in
Casablanca a bunch of Germans are
standing around in a Moroccan it's
French Morocco occupied French Morocco
bunch of Germans are standing around in
a in a bar owned by Rick Blaine who is
played by Humphrey Bogart in Victor
Laszlo who's a resistance leader is is
there as well and the Germans started
singing the watch on the Rhine which is
a famous Nazi drinking song and and
Victor Laszlo the the heroic resistance
leader says let's pull he goes to the
band he says it's time to play La
Marseillaise
[Music]
[Applause]
okay this is from 1942 one of the things
that makes that seem so effective by the
way is that a lot of the actors in that
scene where actual expatriates from
Europe who've been expelled by the Nazis
or had to flee the Nazis and this was
made in 1942 in the middle of the war so
the idea that Lemar sales was eventually
going to triumph over the watch on the
Rhine was still very much in doubt at
the time what a phenomenal movie it's
such a great movie though the one
quibble I have with Casablanca is that
paul-henri like when I watch the movie I
don't understand why Ingrid Bergman
would be into Humphrey Bogart over Paul
Henreid Paul Henreid character is just a
much better character part of it is that
Humphrey Bogart's a little too old for
the part but obviously a fantastic movie
and a great national anthem okay time
for a bunch of things that I hate okay
so we begin with things I hate today
with jussie Smollett so you'll recall
the jussie Smollett claimed that at 2:00
a.m. on a Chicago Street he was accosted
by two mega fans who started shouting at
him the F word and the N word and then
suggested that they that he had invaded
Magga country on the streets of Chicago
roped a noose around his neck and hit
him with bleach now there's no camera
evidence that any of this happened he
was walking home the camera stops for
about there bunch of cameras in Chicago
he's missing on camera for about 60
seconds during that 60-second break
suddenly a rope appears around his neck
or a clothesline
he walks wearing that straight through
his Lobby at home straight through his
Lobby he's still carrying a Subway
sandwich by the way straight through the
lobby up to his room waits 40 minutes to
call the police and then when the police
come and they say okay well can we see
your phone cuz you said you were on the
phone at the time he says no you can't
see my phone then finally when he turned
over his phone records he turned them
over and they were so redacted that they
no longer that they no longer were of
any use to the police which is what the
police said
well now Jesse Smollett who again this
story was never particularly credible
now he goes on Good Morning America he
says how dare anyone just trust my story
and he cries about it I'm pissed off
what is it that has you so angry is it
that the attacker is the attackers but
it's also the attacks it's like you know
at first it was a thing of like listen
if I tell the truth then that's it
because it's truth
then it became a thing of light oh how
can you doubt that like how do you how
do you not believe that it's the truth
and then it became a thing of like oh
it's not necessarily that you don't
believe that this is the truth you don't
even want to see the truth Oh since that
we all don't want to see the truth which
is that you were walking down a street
in Chicago at 2:00 a.m. when a bunch of
when two Magga fans who watch Empire
recognized you and shouted about Magga
country and beat you up and kicked in
the ribs and roped roped a noose around
your neck and poured bleach on you and
then you waited 40 minutes to call the
police didn't turn over your phone
changed your story multiple times why
wouldn't anyone but must be natural
American racism
it can't be skepticism of stories that
seem like they don't hold it's got to be
natural American racism that exactly
that that's what's going on here this
implication is is really obviously
stupid but I guess that GMA will run
with it ABC News what will simply run
with it without asking the serious
questions about whether the story is
even true or not like well you need some
evidence you would assume there'd be
some evidence that this thing happened
in the first place
hey other things that I hate today so
Trevor Noah deeply unfunny human on
Comedy Central
he was talking about Howard Schultz
Howard Schultz of course the former
Starbucks CEO who said on TV something
unsayable he said I don't see color by
which he meant I judge people as
individuals not that he's colorblind or
that he has no capacity to see the
difference between a black person and a
white person in terms of his visual
fields but that when he looks at people
he doesn't see them as members of a race
first which is what we should all aspire
to I thought I thought that was the idea
but according to Trevor Noah that's very
bad white people aren't allowed to say
this I didn't see color as a young boy
and I honestly don't see color now oh
this works out great because I don't
hear bullets
yeah I'm sorry but you have to see color
there's nothing wrong with seeing color
you just shouldn't treat people
differently because of their color but
you have to see it especially if you
want to be president you know what's
interesting you don't see interesting to
me is that it's always white people who
say they don't see color I've never
heard a black person like hey yo do
y'all know each human is white okay well
that's not what he meant
obviously Howard Schultz again did not
mean he doesn't see that somebody is
black he meant I don't treat people
differently based on their race and
everyone should aspire to that including
Trevor Noah in fact Trevor Noah
basically says that he says that we
should see color in the sense that we
know people are of different races and
then we should treat them exactly the
same the attempt to paint all white
people as racist for saying that they
are not racist is really amazing so
Howard Schultz says I'm not a racist and
then Trevor knows why are white people
always saying they're not racist
probably because they're racist hey oh
my god what exactly is the guy supposed
to say so if he says that I do see color
but I get over that and I treat people
as individuals in spite of that then
it's oh you see color that means that
you are probably a racist then if say
well you know I don't see color in the
sense that people are black people are
white don't really care well that means
that you're a racist because you don't
see color but we know you see color so
you're hiding your racism I mean this is
if she's a witch
throw her in the water and if she drowns
that means she's innocent and if she
floats that means she's guilty that's
what we're doing on race now it's really
pathetic
all righty we'll be back here later
today with two more hours of live
programming go check it out over at Daly
we're calm subscribers you can get the
rest of the content I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19